EVERYONE NICE TO SEE EVERYONE.
THAT'S. MORE. WELCOME TO WITH
LOCAL COMMITTEE HEARING HIS
WITH IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TO. WE
ARE CONTINUING TO PRAY PHYSICAL
DISTANCING IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SO WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRING THE MASS BE WORN AND
DOES PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEM BE
MAINTAINED BY EVERYONE PRESENT
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT THE
VIDEO CREWS CONFERENCING SITE.
IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE
CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY.
TODAY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO WE CAN AT- MAINTAIN
APPROPRIATE FACING. THERE'S
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCE
THE PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL. PLEASE LISTEN FOR MY
PROMPT TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE. OF THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE. FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO YOU CAN ALSO FIND THE
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING. ON
BEGINS A PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST. AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST A BILL. YOU'LL
REMAIN ON LIVE LINE. AND WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATOR PHONE LINE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE THREE
NINE FIVE EIGHT. AND MY STUFF
WILL BE THERE TO HELP YOU. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE CONTINUE USING
METHODS TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE FACE.
TODAY WE HAVE NINE AGENDAS
UNYTE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TODAY.
FIVE OF THOSE ARE WILL USE ME-
FOUR OF THOSE ITEMS ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT. ARKANSAS
CALENDAR CONSISTS OF THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY. I ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB SIX EIGHT SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SEE OURSELVES.
HI ADAM EIGHT AB THREE THREE
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL
APPROVED HERE TO. AND ITEMS NOT
AB ZERO TWO BY ASSEMBLY WARD.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THIRTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SYMBOL
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND WILL BE
HEARD TODAY. WE WILL BE HEARING
ALL OTHER BILLS IN THE ORDER
SHOWN ON THE AGENDA. WE WILL
TAKE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR
EACH BILL. THESE WITNESSES WILL
HAVE THREE MINUTES EACH TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY ALL
SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL. ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION MAY PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN ANY ORDER SO IT'S
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT SO ANY
ORDER THIS YEAR. OKAY LET'S SEE
IF I HAVE A QUORUM HERE ONE TWO
THREE FOUR YEAH. OKAY WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND SO WE'LL HAVE OF
COURSE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY HERE
PRESIDENT LUCKY. HELLO THERE
WILL PRESENT FIRMWARE BACK HERE
REMEMBER REPRESENTS RAIN.
REMOTE PRESS. LET'S WE-
ROBERT RIVAS YEAH ROBERT RIVAS
PRESENT. VOEPEL YOU. VOEPEL
PRESS. AND YOU HAVE. THANK YOU
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
SECRETARY I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW-
AND THE ENTERTAIN FROM DINNER A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY WE HAVE A- BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BORDER HARPER AND THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RATE
OF. RAM FOR ALMOST. AT WORK
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
ALRIGHT LACKEY HELLO I WILL I
BOERNER HORVATH I ROBERT I.
RABO FIVE REBELS I LET'S RIVAS
ROBERT. ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL
OKAY I. THAT IS SIX. THANK YOU
CAN CALENDARS UP ALL RIGHT I
ALSO LIKE TO- DO HAVE THE
COMMITTEE RULES REGION. OKAY
I'M NOT GOING AND LET'S START
OUR BILL IS ITEM NUMBER ONE. AB
FOUR EIGHTY BY THIS MEMBER CHIU
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
COLLEAGUES MANAGER APPRECIATE
YOU AND YOUR STAFF
CONSIDERATION AND DELIBERATION
OVER AB FORTY ONE. OUR BILL
WILL INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY BETWEEN POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE. AS A
FORMER CRIMINAL PROSECUTOR I
KNOW AND BELIEVE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA OUR
FOUR PARTNERS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. WE ALSO KNOW THAT THEY
ARE NOT MILITARY GENERALS AND
THAT THERE SHOULD BE POLICIES
THAT GOVERN THE WEAPONS AND
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY CARRY TO
REFLECT THAT REALITY.
CALIFORNIA'S LED THE NATION AND
HAVING PROCURED THE MOST
MILITARY WEAPONRY OF ANY STATE.
LAST SUMMER. OUR STATE SAW AN
ALARMING RANGE OF EQUIPMENT AND
ACTION WHEN POLICE SPRAY TEAR
GAS FOR MILITARY GRENADE
LAUNCHERS AT PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS. AND SHOT RUBBER
BULLETS AT UNARMED CITIZENS
FROM BEHIND ARMORED VEHICLES-
BEEN A NUMBER OF STUDIES THAT
HAVE SHOWN. THAT MORE MILITARY
EQUIPMENT AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS INCREASED THE
RATE OF VIOLENT INCIDENTS
INCLUDING POLICE SHOOTINGS THAT
OCCUR IN THESE JURISDICTIONS.
THE DECISIONS OF HOW AND WHEN
TO DEPLOY THE SENSITIVE
EQUIPMENT WAS LEFT UP TO
INDIVIDUAL OFFICERS AT THE
SCENE THIS PAST YEAR. WITHOUT
UNIFORM PROTOCOL OR TRAINING.
WE KNOW THAT THIS WOULD BE
UNACCEPTABLE IN WAR ZONES LIKE
IRAQ OR AFGHANISTAN. WHERE THIS
EQUIPMENT WAS DESIGNED TO BE
USED. AB FORTY ONE WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. AGENCIES
TO WORK WITH THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND GOVERNING BOARDS TO DROP
APPROPRIATE MILITARY EQUIPMENT
USE AND IMPACT POLICIES THAT
CAN BE DELIBERATED AND APPROVED
IN A PUBLIC SETTING. THE PUBLIC
HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW WHEN AND
WHY LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
BELIEVETHAT THEY NEED TO USE
MILITARY CALIBER COMMITMENT
ESPECIALLY WHEN OUR POLICE ARE
USING PUBLIC DOLLARS TO
PURCHASE AND MAINTAIN ADEQUATE.
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO TURN
OVER TOLD WITNESSES. GO AHEAD
WE HAVE. FIRST WITH THIS. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
WONDERFUL GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
PROVIDING YOU HERE TODAY. MY
NAME IS BRIANNA CHRYSLER I AM
AN ATTORNEY WITH FIVE NOBODY
KNOWS THE NEEDLE AND I AM HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF WOMEN
FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA AS A
PROUD CO SPONSOR- AB FOUR EIGHT
ONE. CALIFORNIA POLICE AGENCIES
HAVE BEEN MILITARIZING FOR
JACKIE WITH LITTLE TO NO
OVERSIGHT- THROUGH ONE PROGRAM
THE TEN THIRTY THREE PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA POLICE HAVE ACQUIRED
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS OF SURPLUS
MILITARY EQUIPMENT. INCLUDING
MINE RESISTANT AMBUSH PROTECTED
VEHICLES UNMANNED GROUND
VEHICLES ASSAULT RIFLES AND
NIGHT VISION SNIPER SCOPES.
OTHER FEDERAL PROGRAMS DON'T
REQUIRE ANY REPORTING BUT A
CATALOG WITH EVERYTHING FROM
ARMORED VEHICLES TONIGHT VISION
GOGGLES. WHO IS THE ENEMY ARE
TRYING TO COMBAT. THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FOUND NO
TRACE POLICE FORCES MOST OFTEN
HE IN BLACKIE. EVEN AFTER
CONTROLLING CRIME RIGHT AND
SEVERAL STUDIES FOUND THAT
CORRELATION BETWEEN INCREASED
POLICE MILITARY. AND INCREASED
POLICE CAN. FOR ALL THIS HARM
THERE IS NO BENEFIT. RATIO
MILITARY. FAILED TO CRIME SALES
TO A HANDS OFF SAFETY. AND
FAILED SUPPORT HOW TRUST IN MY
FOURTH. EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT ONE
PRESENT AND EASY FIX. POLICE
AGENCIES INCLUDING THOSE THAT
CONTACT WITH OR ARE HOUSED
WITHIN SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALREADY
REPORT INFORMATION ABOUT
PLANNED PURCHASES DURING THE
ANNUAL BUDGET REVIEW PROCESS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL DETAIL ABOUT THE
EQUIPMENT SHOT AS WELL AS THE
USAGE POLICY BEFORE POLICE CAN
BRING THE MOST EXTREME WARLIKE
EQUIPMENT INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS A MINIMAL ASK OF OUR
PUBLIC SERVANTS. POLICE MAY
CLAIM THEY NEED THIS EQUIPMENT
WE ARE JUST SAYING THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE PUBLIC
SHOULD HAVE A VOICE IN THE
PROCESS. AB FOUR EIGHT ONE IT
IS A COMMON SENSE SOLUTION TO
ADVANCE RACIAL JUSTICE REDUCE
POLICE VIOLENCE AND IN CERTAIN
BASIC TRANSPARENCY MEASURES.
ALL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
INCLUDING THOSE HEADED BY
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE SUBJECT
TO OVERSIGHT. THIS BASIC
PRINCIPLE OF GOVERNMENT MUST WE
MUST BE IMPLEMENTED WITH REGARD
TO EQUIPMENT. MEANT FOR THE
BATTLEFIELD. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT ONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE MODERATOR WE
HAVING ANOTHER WITNESS IN
SUPPORT PLEASE. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR YES WE CAN. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK NUMBER MA'AM TO AFTERNOON
SHARE AND- MY NAME IS GOPI
SOMEWHAT A AND I'M WITH THE
FROM OF. AT THE BONTA AND ALL
WITH THE POPULATION WHICH IS
THE BIG WHITE OF PLAN WHO LOST
SOME PEOPLE FINALLY ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY AND- CALIFORNIA
FAMILY LIKE MY- I'M HERE TO ASK
YOU SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
EIGHTY. AND THOUSAND FIVE SAN
SHERIFF'S THAT THE CHRISTOPHER
LEVEL SHOT MIGHT JONATHAN THE
MAN SIXTEEN HI IN THE BACK WITH
CHAO AND- WHICH EXPAND UPON
ENTERING THE PARK TO THE MARC
TO THE A FAN THANK WELL IF AND
CONGRESS MARKING BY. BLOOD LOSS
AND INCREASE THE CHANCES OF
HITTING VITAL ORGANS MY COUSIN
TORTURED DEATH HE HAD TWO
WOUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN WITH LEFT
ON THE FOR. THANK WILL BE YES
MY BEFORE CHRISTOPHER AND LYFT
HAD KILLED ANOTHER LIKE YOU
KNOW SERGIO SHOOTING HIM TO
EIGHT ALSO HIGH CAN AND- IN I
CAN MAKE CARE AND ALL LET'S TO
DIE WELL IN. THAT THERE NO
JUSTIFICATION FOR SHOOTING
HIKES AND- ON HUMAN BEING TO
TWENTY TRYING. A MILITARY
WEAPON ONLY EMPOWERS THEM TO
TREAT OUR COMMUNITIES LIKE
WATER BOND WE HAVE THE NATIONAL
PARK FOR EMERGENCIES WELL
THERE'S NO NEED TO PERPETUATE A
MILITARIZED WILL BE FOR YOUR
MIND THAT COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
HAVE EXPERIENCE TOO MANY YEAR
OF TERRORIZING INFORMATIK
VIOLENCE AT THE HANDS OF POLICE
FOR KIDS THAT ARE INCREASINGLY
BECOMING MORE MILITARIZED. HIGH
CALIBER AMMUNITION APPOINT
FIFTY CALIBER OR MORE SIMILAR
TO THE ONE THAT WAS USED
AGAINST MY COUSIN ANSWER TO
WEIGHT IF ONE OF THEIR YOUTH
TYPES OF MILITARY EQUIPMENT
THAT IS INCLUDED IN THE BILL
FOR REGULATION EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE IS ONE POSITIVE
THAT. WOULD BE MILITARY THE
POLICE WILL ACT AND VIOLENCE
AGAINST BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
I LIVE VERY AT EIGHT AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY WE'RE NOT
TAKE THE PRIME WITNESS IN POP.
AND THAT IS- SUB MUCH MUSCULAR
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. WATER
WRITERS ON THE PHONE I BELIEVE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT ON THE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MUCH LUCKY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE- AS A PRACTICAL
MATTER DEGRADATION OF MAIL
THREE STAR CLASS PROPERTY OFTEN
REQUIRES OPERATORS TO RESPOND
QUICKLY WITHOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ENGAGE IN LEGISLATIVE BODY
REGARDING EACH CUR CHAT. EVEN
IF THE BILL ONLY APPLIES TO THE
FIRST TIME AGENCY SEEKS TO
ACQUIRE CERTAIN QUICK MAN
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE WOULD
STILL SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES AND THE
ATTEMPTED OCCUPATION
ADDITIONALLY THE TYPE OF
PROPERTY CONTEMPLATED BY THIS
BILL IS EXCEEDINGLY FAST AND
INCLUDES ITEMS COMMONLY USED.
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT TOUCH
HELLACOPTERS COMMAND AND
CONTROL VEHICLE REACHING
APPARATUS. AND WHITE HELMET AND
SHIELD. HOWEVER EVEN IF MEASURE
LACK THAT IDENTIFIED. AND OF
THE EQUIPMENT IS BEING. WE
WOULD REMAIN OPPOSED AB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE INTERESTING WITH THE
OF IN THE MEDIA CO. OFFICERS TO
QUIET RECRUITMENT AT A COST
SAVING COULD APPOINTMENT FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES.
USUALLY IN LIKE THE CHAIRS ARE
CERTAINLY CAPABLE OF RESPONDING
TO THE CONCERNS OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS CONSTITUENTS. WHEN
IT COMESTO THE PURCHASING AND
DEPLOYMENT OF APPROPRIATE.
EQUIPMENT SHOULD THEY ARISE-
THERE THE BILL'S A REPORTING
WITH. MANDATE THAT LONG NOT
ONLY DESCRIBE AND WHERE SUCH
EQUIPMENT REVIEWS. BUT ALSO AND
NOW BECAUSE OF IT ANY
DISCRIMINATORY DISPARAGE. ANY
OTHER ADVERSE IMPACT THAT THE
USE OF MILITARY EQUIPMENT MAY
HAVE HAD ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY
WELFARE AND CIVIL RIGHTS AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES. AND ON ANY
COMMUNITY- GROUP. THESE
PROVISIONS ON UNNECESSARILY
BURDENSOME AND PRESUPPOSED
INAPPROPRIATELY THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT LAW ENFORCEMENT YOU.
LIKE IT QUIT MEANT AND
TECHNOLOGY NECESSARILY
NEGATIVELY. IMPACTS COMMUNITY.
AS I ALL KNOW TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN GROUND BEEF THE MORE
RELIGIOUS. EIGHTY THREE ONE
THIRTY ONE. THAT DID NOT GO AS
FAR AS TWO REQUIRED BODY
APPROVAL FOR THE ACQUISITION OF
MILITARY EQUIPMENT- IN HIS VETO
MESSAGE SHOULD. THAT THE
CURRENT LET'S NOT ONLY INCLUDE
ITEMS THAT ARE CLEARLY NO
INTERESTING STYLE BUT MANY THAT
ARE COMMONLY USED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND DO NOTMERIT
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO
TECHNICAL OPPOSITION. NOT IT'S
OUR VIEW THAT THIS BILL CREATES
AN UNNECESSARY BUREAUCRATIC
HURDLE WITHOUT COMMENSURATE
PUBLIC BENEFIT. AND THAT'S WHY
HE SB CODE THAT AB THIRTY
THIRTY ONE. AND FORTY THREE
DOLLARS WILL RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT SAID COMMITTEE
VOTE NO ON EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- BEFORE
I GO AND I'M GOING TO ASK IF
THERE ARE ANY OTHER PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
HEARING NONE- WE ARE NOW GOING
TO MOVE INTO SUPPORT AND-
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I ASKED
THE FOLLOWING PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
THE POSITION ON THE BILL.
MODERATOR. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN. ZERO OUR
FIRST LINE COME FROM MINE TO.
TWO TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER
POLLOCK I'M A MEMBER OF THE
THIRD SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE BAY AREA AND I SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT ONE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
TWO EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JEAN MOSES I'M
FROM OAKLAND AND A MEMBER OF ST
INACTION EAST BAY AND I SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE UP
BY TWO SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE TO SEVENTEEN. HELLO
EVERYONE MY NAME IS NATHANIEL
PHILLIPS I AM WITH THE AMERICAN
FRIENDS SERVICE COMMITTEE AND I
FERVENTLY SUPPORT CERVANTES
SUPPORT AB FOUR EIGHT ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK. NEXT TO A LINE OF TWO
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ERIC
MORTON SMITH AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF PAUL WHO WE CAN BE A
LINE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
WE ARE COSPONSORED THE AB PORT
ONE AREN'T STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MICROLINER. TWO
THIRTY THREE. THEY LASSEN SORRY
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS ELLIE AND
WHAT AN ORGANIZER WITH THE
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION
INSTRUCTOR FOR AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA STOP
COALITION AND- BOB COSPONSORS
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT TO THE LINE UP TO
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BOND RAP ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A LOT OF
TWO OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS BARBARA
WELL I'M A MEMBER OF THE
BERKELEY QUAKER MEETING AND I
AM SUPPORT IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AB EIGHT FORTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE UP TO TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M SORRY
I'M IN OPPOSITION SHOULD I CALL
BACK NO YOU'RE FINE GO AHEAD OF.
OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT- RANDY
PERRY WITH ERIN REDUCES IT'S
HOW THEY HAPPENED MARK WE WERE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE OF
TWO TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
SIR MY NAME IS JOHN LINDSAY
POLAND I'M WITH THE AMERICAN
FRIENDS SERVICE COMMITTEE AND
WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND AS A REMINDER IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ACTUALLY A LOT
OF TWO THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS JIM LINDBERG
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE FRENCH
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION THAT
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANKS A
LOT OF TWO OH SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BRANDON UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HARPER AND MY MOMENT
WE HAVE TWO MORE IN QUEUE TO
GET THEIR LINE NUMBER. AND AS A
REMINDER IT IS ONE NINE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION. ONE
MOMENT WE'LL GET THE LINE
NUMBER. AND MAKOTO LINE OF TWO
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GREGORY CLAIM ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
IN THE PORT. THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU AND NEXT ALTHOUGH
LINE OF- TWO THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
QUITE REACHING THE RIGHT ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH THERAPIST AT THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FORTY ONE
RUNS AND OUR PRODUCTS HEALTH
MONSTER A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS- RIGHT AND- IT'S
A- AS WELL CAN I JUST WEST BOTH.
REAL QUICK. SURE QUICK. ALL
RIGHT IF YOU KNOW YOUR
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR BOYS TO
MEN AND HOW IF YOU'RE JUST IF
YOU JUST CALLS CALIFORNIA
UNITED RESPONSE BUDGET SOCIAL
WORKERS FOR EQUITY IN
LEADERSHIP AND THE W. HEY WOULD
BURN BURN AND I'M STRUCK THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
OUR FINAL ONE COME FROM LINE
TO. TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS PAMELA DRAKE CALLING IN
FROM OAKLAND FIRE OF WHAT THE
WELLSTONE DEMOCRATIC RENEWAL
CLUB I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND BERKELEY
FRIENDS AMONG VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS WE DON'T WANT
TO GO TO WAR AMERICANS. PLEASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OPERATOR MODERATOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE CALL SO I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR TWO THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
OKAY SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. YES.
YES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
SPELL- I DO LIKE IT GIVES LOCAL
CONTROL AND LOCAL OFTEN I HAVE
TO CITIES AND MY DISTRICT THAT
CONTRACT WITH THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT HOW WOULD THAT WORK
WITH- COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT THAT CONTRACTS WITH
LOCAL CITIES SO PERSONAL
APPRECIATE OUR CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY ABOUT THIS I'VE ASKED
THIS TO OUR TEAM AND- YOU RAISE
AN ISSUE THAT FRANKLY WE ARE
GOING TO DO A LITTLE HOMEWORK
ON- SO THE IDEA IS TO GIVE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS LOCAL
CONTROL AND APPRECIATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THIS I THINK
IT'S VERY IN LINE WITH THE
VALUES AND COMMITMENT. OF THE
POLICIES OF THIS COMMITTEE- AND
SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I THINK
THE IDEA OF ENSURING THAT IF
THERE'S A CONTRACT CITY IN A
COUNTY THAT MAYBE CONTRACTING
SOME OF THE SERVICES THAT THAT
LOCAL CITY WOULD HAVE A SAY IN
THIS AND THAT'S A VALUE I WOULD
SUPPORT AS WELL SO MY HOPE IS
IN THE COMING WEEKS WILL BE
ABLE TO FIGURE THAT PIECE OUT
AND THAT THIS BILL IS GOING TO
GO TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AND- HOPEFULLY WILL
WILL HAVE MORE TO SAY ABOUT
THAT IN THE COMING. WEEKS THANK
YOU FOR REYES AND- ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE. K.
SINGH NONE- CONSIDER MOTION.
MMHM SO THEY WERE BARBARA
HARGROVE- THE BILL. THE SECOND
SECOND. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS SECONDED. OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
CHIU COOPER SUGAR CONSIDERATION
THIS IS A BILL ABOUT REBUILDING
COMMUNITY TRUST AND I WANT TO
JUST MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT OF
A LOCAL COMMUNITY CHOOSES TO
SUPPORT ANY LEVEL OR TYPE OF
MILITARY EQUIPMENT THAT THEY
WANT THAT S PERMISSIBLE UNDER
THE BILL ALL WE'RE SAYING IS WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES INVOLVED IN
DECISIONS REGARDING THE LAN-
MILITARY EQUIPMENT WILL BE
RECEIVED AND IT'S REALLY ABOUT
REBUILDING COMMUNITY TRUST WITH
THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THAN. MY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PASS. AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR OFFERING
THE BILL I'M A BIG BELIEVER IN
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN GOVERNMENT. YOUR BILL
PROVIDES BOTH IN THE OF THOSE
PROTECTIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
THE ACQUISITION OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT BY OUR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. I'M ALSO
A BIG BELIEVER IN THE NOTION
THAT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS SHOULD BE JUST THAT
PARTNERS. PARTNERS WITH THE
PEOPLE WE ELECT TO REPRESENT US
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY BUT THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL DOES NOT
PROHIBIT PROHIBIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FROM
REQUIRING MILITARY EQUIPMENT.
IT DOES HOWEVER INSIST ON THE
INVOLVEMENT OF OUR GOVERNING
BOARDS AND THE PUBLIC WHEN
THESE DECISIONS ARE TO BE
CONSIDERED. THIS IS AN APPROACH
I STRONGLY SUPPORT I AM PLEASED
TO VOTE AYE FOR YOUR BILL
TODAY. AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
HAPPEN TO THANK YOU SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY I. IRAQI NO LUCKY
THOUGH BLOOM WILL I. MONARCH HI
WATER HARBOR I RAMOSE. REBELS
NOT VOTING LET'S. BUT THAT THE
OTHER ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
I VOEPEL THE VOEPEL NO. FIVE
TWO FIVE PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
YEAH ADDITIONAL- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. COOL FIFTY SIX ON OF THE
FIVE NUMBERS TO AB POINT SIX
AND MORE OF OUR YOU HAVE TO
HAVE. IT. GOOD AFTERNOON BOB
MANAGER COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION ON AB
SEVENTY SIX A- BILL THAT HAS
SET ITS GOALS TO ENSURE THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS PROVIDE
INCENTIVES TO ATTRACT NEW
MANUFACTURING FACILITIES. TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES I THINK THE
ANALYSIS KIND OF EXPLAINS THE
OBJECTIVES HERE I THINK THIS
WILL HELP THE REGION LIKE
IMPERIAL COUNTY WHO SUFFERED
WITH 27% UNEMPLOYMENT. ATTRACTS
A MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION OF
THE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AND THEN WHICH ONE
OF AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
ALMOST. SECOND OKAY- WILL FIRST
GO WITH OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- I BELIEVE WE HAVE ON
THE PHONE SEAN WILCOX FROM THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION. ON THE
PHONE. OKAY THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SEAN MODOC
VICE PRESIDENT OF IMPERIAL
VALLEY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. I'M SPEAKING AND
ON BEHALF IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN TWENTY SIX- AS AN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPER IN THE
COUNTY. JAIL WE OFTEN FIND
OURSELVES IN COMPETITION FOR
PROJECTS THAT WE ARE SEEKING TO
ATTRACT TO THE COUNTY. TO
CREATE JOB OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OUR RESIDENTS OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER IT WAS MENTIONED THAT-
WE OFTEN ARE- YOU KNOW TOUTED
WITH THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT
IN THE STATE AND OFTEN TIMES IN
THE NATION- SO YOU KNOW
SUPPORTING A BILL LIKE THIS
WILL SUPPORT AND CREATE-
BETTER- BETTER AVAILABILITY
FOR- MANUFACTURES. PARTS
COMPONENT IN RELATION TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY. AND
HELP US SOLIDIFY ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVES TO FACILITATE THE
ATTRACTION OF THE SPECTACULAR
PRODUCT PROJECTS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER PRIMARY-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OKAY WHAT
ARE WE MOVED TO- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. HI IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TO THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR- OR SUPPORT. OKAY
MODERATE WILL GO TO THE PHONES
WE'LL TAKE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND IN OPPOSITION. ZERO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB.
SEVEN TWO SIX. AND ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE ONE IN Q. WE JUST
MINUTES. THAT'LL COME FROM LINE
OF. NINE TO FORTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO YEAH GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
ANASTASIA CULTURE COME WITH
CALIFORNIA ADVISORS ON BEHALF
OF ENERGY SOURCE MINERALS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TWO SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THAT WAS THE ONLY ONE WE
HAD IN Q. OKAY WELL THAT'S ROB
POSITION OR A FORM OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE- WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OKAY I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD BILL
FOREIGN I WILL BE VOTING HI FOR
TODAY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY I. I'M GLAD
HI THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ROOM LOU
I REMEMBER I REMEMBER REMOTE I
LET'S REVIEW. ROBBERY
ROBERT RIVAS I WILL TELL.
VOEPEL HI NO THE SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL NOT
READILY THANK YOU SO MEMBER.
ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON. TO
HUNCH ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B.
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CORK.
DON'T FALL. I
DON'T. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK IT'S SO
NICE TO SEE AND IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU AS ALWAYS CHAIR- SO
THANK YOU ALL- THE ALAMEDA.
CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT DISTRICT
LAW HAS REMAINED UNCHANGED IT'S
AN ACT MEANT. IN NINETEEN FIFTY
FIVE. AS A RESULT B. AC TRANSIT
DISTRICT LAWS OUTDATED THAT
DOES NOT REFLECT THE TRANSIT
DISTRICT'S CURRENT NEEDS
CHANGES IN TECHNOLOGIES.
ADJUSTMENTS TO OTHER CALIFORNIA
COACH AB SEVENTY EIGHTY FOUR
MAKES TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO ADDRESS THESE. AND
PROVIDES OPERATIONAL
FLEXIBILITY TO THE AC TRANSIT
DISTRICT AS THEY CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION SERVICES
TO THE PUBLIC. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY ARE TWO KEY WITNESSES
FROM AC TRANSIT BY WITH ME I
MEAN ON THE PHONE I BELIEVE-
AND THEY WILL- DISCUSS THIS IN
MORE DETAIL. MODERATOR WE'RE
LOOKING FOR JILL SPRAYING OR
CLAUDIA BURGERS PLEASE. THEY'RE
BOTH ON THE LINE AND BOTH HAVE
OPEN LINE THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN. GOOD AFTERNOON I AM
GLAD TO BE ABLE TO LOOK
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
AND COMMUNITY RELATIONS AT
EIGHTY TRANSIT. EIGHTY TRANSIT
IS SPONSORING AB SEVENTY FOUR
IN A EFFORT TO UPDATE AND
MODERNIZE PROVISION OF EIGHTY
TRIANGLE AUTHORIZING STATUTE.
MANY OF THESE CODE SECTIONS
HAVE NOT BEEN AMENDED SINCE
THEY WERE ENACTED IN NINETEEN
FIFTY FIVE I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMAN QUIRK FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF THE TRANSIT. EIGHTY TRANSIT
OF THE THIRD LARGEST PUBLIC BUS
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA SERVING
THIRTEEN CITIES AND ADJACENT
UNINCORPORATED AREAS IN ALAMEDA
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. EIGHTY
TRYING TO HAVE THE SERVING THE
EAST BAY SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
AND CURRENTLY OPERATES ONE OF
THE MOST ADVANCED ZERO EMISSION
FLEET IN THE STATE WITH TWENTY
TWO FIELD FELL AND FIVE BATTERY
ELECTRIC BUSES. AMONG THE LONG
OVERDUE CHANGES THAT AB SEVENTY
FOUR MAKES ITS TO REPEAL THE
CONFUSING FOR NATION LANGUAGE
AND SIMPLY THAT WOULD MAKE
EIGHTY TRANSIT AT THE RAPID
TRANSIT DISTRICT. FORMED
PURSUANT TO THIS AUTHORITY. THE
BILL UPDATE PROVISIONS
SPECIFYING SIGNATURE THRESHOLDS
FOR NOMINATION PAPERS AND ALLOW
THE NOMINATION PAPERS MAY ALSO
BE SUBMITTING. COMMITTED WITH A
FILING FEE IN LIEU OF
SIGNATURES. THE BILL ALSO
MODERNIZES THE ACT TO REFLECT
THE ABILITY TO USE DIGITAL
SIGNATURES AFFECT THE FIGHT IN
EXISTING LAWS IS IT WELL AS
MAKING OTHER NUMEROUS TECHNICAL
CHANGES. ON BEHALF OF THE
TRANSIT I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WITH
ME TODAY IS JOKES BREAK. AC
TRANSIT GENERAL COUNSEL. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M JOE FRANK GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR AC TRANSIT. I'VE
SERVED IN THIS ROLE FOR A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR OF PRIOR TO
MY JOINING AC TRANSIT THE BOARD
DIRECTED THE GENERAL COUNSEL'S
OFFICE TO REVIEW ITS
AUTHORIZING STATUTE TO ADDRESS
INCONSISTENCIES OUTDATED
REFERENCES AND THE ABILITY TO
UTILIZE MODERN TECHNOLOGY SUCH
AS DIGITAL SIGNATURES. THE
CONTENT OF EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR WAS DEVELOPED BY MY OFFICE
IN CONSULTATION WITH OUTSIDE
COUNSEL. IN ADDITION THE
PROVISIONS HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED
BY THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND
SEVERAL PUBLICLY NOTICED BOARD
MEETING. GIVEN THE EXTENSIVE
REVIEW AND DISCUSSION DETECTIVE
HAD ON THESE CHANGES THE TIME
HAS COME TO UPDATE AC TRANSIT'S
AUTHORIZING STATUTE. AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR. MANY OF THE
CHANGES ARE TECHNICAL I'M HERE
TO ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ARE THERE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. SEEING NONE MORE HEARING
NONE- WE'LL NOW TAKE A
MODERATOR- TESTIMONY FROM
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION JUST THE NAME. AND
ORGANIZATION ANY POSITION ON
THE BILL PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
FOR AB SEVENTY FOUR. ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR ANY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. I MATTER MODERATOR
AND- WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK
YOU AND IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
FORTY TWO OR TWO. SEEING NONE
OF WILL MOVE ON ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING NO I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION PLEASE. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MORAL HALLMARK IN THE RE
HAVING A SECOND BY- MISTER
ROBERT RIVAS. OKAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER CORK ARM
AS YOU SAW THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I REQUEST FULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. GREAT
YOU KNOW THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORTY NINE
DO RECOMMENDED TO PASS ON THIS
I THINK IT'S GOING TO OPEN THE
EYES OF OTHER DISTRICTS TO
REALIZE IT'S TIME TO UPGRADE AN
UPDATE. SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THAT FORWARD AND I CAN
SEE SOME OF MY DISTRICTS- GOING
TO BE VERY HAPPY ABOUT THIS
BILL SO THANK YOUSO MUCH. AND
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AND WE ARE CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY ALRIGHT LACKEY I'M
LUCKY I LOOM. WILL OUR- WATER
FOR BACK I READ LOS. LABELS I
THREE OF US. THREE I ROBERT
RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I WILL TELL
RIGHT VOEPEL ALL RIGHT. YOU
HAVE ZERO. EIGHT ZERO YOUR OUT
AND FOR SOME MEMBER THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY LET'S SEE HERE
DO WE HAVE A. SECRET SILVA DAY
AND. OKAY WHILE WE WAIT FOR-
PRESENTERS- WE CAN ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE ROLES I HAVE A MOTION.
SECOND YOUR MOTION BY SOME
REMEMBER BORA HARWORTH AND WE
HAVE A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM. GLOBAL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI KERRY HI LACKEY
LACKEY I BLOW. I BURKE HARD
OCK I REMEMBER I READ BOTH
MEMOS I THREE OF US THREE OF US
I ROBERT RE. VOEPEL RIGHT
VOEPEL ALL RIGHT. SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO COMMITTEE RULES ARE
OUT. AND WE'RE WAITING FOR
TRUE- OTHERS SEEING HERE.
THIRTY ONE FOR. OKAY I THINK WE
SHOULD GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
RULE FOR THE BILL'S WE'VE
MISSED HERE- THAT'S A CURRENTLY
FOR AB FOR IS FOR A NUMBER OF
THAT ONE FORMER. ANYONE WELL
NUMBER ONE WE ARE AT. FOUR TWO.
CALL THE ROLL YES PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB FOUR EIGHTY ONE
CHOOSE MOTION IS TO PASS.
RAMOSE RAMOS I USE REVERSE
THREE OF US I THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY. SIX TWO YEAH THAT'S
HIS BILL. LEVEL. THREE WHAT
DOES NOT PRODUCE. YOUR VOTE IS
FAR TWO I'M BILLS FIVE TWO.
OKAY MISTER CHOOSE AS OUT FIVE
TWO- MYSTERY OF US WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR BILL. OKAY.
SO THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SIX. AB
TWO SEVERAL ONE ROBERT RIVAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MYSTERY
THIS. SALUMI THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR COLLEAGUES- LIKE TO THINK
OUR COMMITTEE STAFF- FOR THE
CONSIDERATION ENGAGEMENT ON THE
SUPPORT OF OUR DISTRICT AND
REGION- THIS LEGISLATION SEND
THE BILL TO SEVENTY ONE WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE SANTA CLARA WATER
DISTRICT ARE VALLEY WATER TO
USE EIGHT BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT SYSTEM. IN
SELECTING THE CONSTRUCTION
CRAP- CONTRACTOR FOR A MAJOR
MAJOR SEISMIC RETROFIT PROJECT
ANDERSON DAMAGE THE SILICON
VALLEY'S LARGEST AND MOST
CRITICAL LOCAL WATER STORAGE
FACILITY. AND THIS LEGISLATION
IS NECESSARY IT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE UNDER CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW VALLEY WATER
MUST. SELECT A CONTRACTOR
THROUGH THE MOST COMMON
PROCUREMENT PROCEDURE USE WHICH
IS A LOW BID PROCUREMENT
SYSTEM. RATHER THAN BY BEST
VALUE AND AS WE KNOW THE BEST
VALUE. PROCUREMENT SYSTEM. HEY
IS- IT CONSIDERS FACTORS OTHER
THAN ONLY PRICE- SUCH AS THE
QUALIFICATIONS AND EXPERTISE OF
VENDORS OR CONTRACTORS. IN
INDEPENDENT BOARD OF
CONSULTANTS CONSISTING OF SOME
OF THE NATION'S FOREMOST DAM
SAFETY EXPERTS. HAVE
RECOMMENDED THE USE OF A BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT SYSTEM AND
SELECTED A CONTRACTOR FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT AND
UNDERSTAND DUE TO ITS COMPLEX
DESIGN ITS DELIVERY AND
INSTALLATION. I IT SHOULD BE
NOTED THAT OTHER MAJOR SERVICES
STORAGE PROJECTS IN OUR STATE
VERY SIMILAR TO THIS ONE. ARE
ALREADY AUTHORIZED FOR BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT OF CONTRACTOR
SELECTION. THIS IS A MAJOR
MAJOR PROJECT FOR OUR REGION
ACCORDING TO A DAM SAFETY
DIRECTIVE ISSUED BY THE FEDERAL
ENERGY REGULATORY COMMISSION
JUST LAST YEAR. THEY STATED
THAT THE SAFETY RISK AT THIS
PARTICULAR DAM ANDERSON DAM IS
UNACCEPTABLY HIGH. AUTHORIZING
THE USE FOR BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT WILL ALLOW THE
SAFEST AND BEST OVERALL VALUE
FOR THE REMOVAL AND- AN EXPERT
REPLACEMENT OF THIS CRITICAL
WATER STORAGE PROJECT. SO I
JUST LISTEN ALSO ENSURES THEY
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
WILL BE EMPLOYED AS PROJECT.
AND IT'S- EXPECTED TO GENERATE
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED JOBS IN FOR ALL THESE
REASONS RESPECT US WHEN I VOTE.
AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO DEPUTY OPERATING OFFICER
VALLEY WATER CHRIS HAKES. I TO
EXPLAIN MORE ABOUT THE ANDERSON
DAM PROJECT IN THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU MATT THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH. MODERATOR CHRIS
TAKES. YOUR LINE AND EVERYONE
HERE YES. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REPLACE ALL MY
**** CRITICS AND THE DEPUTY
OPERATING OFFICER FOR DAM%
SAFETY AND CATHOLIC REPORT
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT ALSO KNOWN AS VALLEY
WATER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
READERSHIP ASSEMBLY AB TWO
SEVEN ONE WILL AUTHORIZED BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT ANDERSON
DOWNSIZED RETROFIT PROJECT AT
THE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR REPLACEMENT OF
THE EXISTING DAMAGES VULNERABLE
TO FAILURE DURING A LARGE
EARTHQUAKE THIS PROJECT WILL
INCLUDE DOWNTURN INPUT
IMPROVEMENTS FOR BOTH FLOOD
PROTECTION AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
ALL MENTION THE WEEK FEDERAL
REGULATORY COMMISSION- LEADER
REGULATOR THE FEDERAL ENERGY
REGULATORY COMMISSION AS PART
OF ITS REVIEW PROCESS AN
INDEPENDENT WORKING TOWARDS
THIS MORE HAS BEEN THAT- THE
BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT IS THE
PROPER METHOD TO USE IN THIS
SITUATION HOME AND OF COURSE
THE INDEPENDENT BOARD OF
CONSULTANTS ARE THE LEADING
EXPERTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
INSTANTIATE THE- ALL WITH THE
LIFE SAFETY OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AT RISK
THIS PROJECT IS TOO IMPORTANT
TO MANDATE IT'S CONSTRUCTION
THE LOWEST BIDDER. CONSTRUCTED
IN NINETEEN FIFTY THE CURRENT
DAM GREAT THE LARGEST WORKING
MORE IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND
PROVIDE INTERNET ALSO
PROTECTION PERSONAL
COMPLEXITIES DURING THE RAINY
SEASON THE WATER SHOULD REDUCE
MORE WATER THAN THE DANCE MALL
OUTLET CAN RELEASED RESULTING
IN FILLING OF THE RESERVOIR
DESPITE DECIDED RESTRICTION TO
KEEP TRYING TO HELP 3% OF ITS
CURRENT CAPACITY. THE NEW SUCH
CRITICAL PROJECT WILL ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND MANY MORE I'D
LIKE THE GAME THING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REVIEWS FOR OFFERING
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY ONE AND FOR
ITS EFFORTS TO GET THE ACCIDENT
PROJECT CONSTRUCTED IN THE
STATE AND FEDERAL MATTER WE
STILL NAPLES VALLEY WATER VIEWS
DECIDED TO TERMINATE METHOD AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE MATH BASED
COP DAM SAFETY EXPERTS. ABOUT
WATER REDUCE YOUR I'VE BUILT ON.
EIGHTY TWO SEVEN ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FURTHER IN
OTHER WRITTEN. IN SUPPORT
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE RAINY HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
TWO. SEEING NONE OTHER ANY
WITNESS PRIME WITNESS ENOUGH TO
THIS BILL. SEEING NONE- DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WE CAN OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINE DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
ON THE PHONE LINE. THANK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE ON THE PHONE WILL
pZERO FOR ANY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO LINE UP
TO SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU TO JACK HOLDEN I'M A
GORY CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AN ACTUAL LINE OF NINE TO
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- RICHARD BILL GATES ON
BEHALF OF DISSERTATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU AS
A REMINDER IT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO SEVEN ONE.
AND WE WILL GO TO THE NEXT LINE.
AND THAT LINE'S GONNA COME FROM
LINE. TWO FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MODERATOR-
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CAN NAY
JEREMY SMITH HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
ARE SUPPORT THIS BILL AS WELL
LIKE WE WERE LAST YEAR LOOKING
FOR MANAGING THE NEXT COMMITTEE
BUT- HAPPEN AGAIN THAT. BUT
PROUD TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THEIR SPONSORS ON THE
DOMESTIC YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE ONE MONTH LEFT
WE HAVE ONE MORE LINE IN Q. AND
THAT'S GOING TO COME FROM TO
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM OR GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
RICHARD MARCUSSEN ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN. ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN THE
PLUMBING HEATING. COOLING
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE IN IN OPPOSITION- THE BILL
CREATES A TWO TIERED
ENFORCEMENT OF THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE PROVISION.
THE ASSEMBLYMAN REAVIS
DISCUSSED. UNDER ONE SCENARIO
THE CONTRACTORS ARE SUBJECT TO
A TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE. AND
POTENTIAL DEPARTMENT INCLUDING
WAS HELD. PROGRESS PAYMENTS.
UNDER THE OTHER SYSTEM. THERE
ARE ONLY SUBJECT TO BINDING
ARBITRATION. THAT IS DONE IN
SECRET. WITH NO GUARANTEE THAT
THERE ARE PENALTIES OR OTHER
PUNISHMENT THAT IS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE USE OF A SKILLED. AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AGAIN. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
THERE ARE NONE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME MANAGER GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND AND WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE SHE'S JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL MANAGER-
AGAIN THIS GREAT WELL
CONGRATULATIONS IS GET THIS
THROUGH FAURIA. AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS
TO PASS. EDU WHERE ARE CARRIED
I. LOVE THE BLOOM. WILL
REMEMBER THAT I BOERNER HORVATH
I ROLES FIVE ROLLS I
THREE OF US THREE OF US IRA.
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL RIGHT NOW HI
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO YOUR
BILLS OUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB THREE FORTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK SILVA
WELCOME MISS KIRK SILVA.
GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON IT IS
CHILLY IN HERE JUST TRYING TO
KEEP EVERYBODY AWAKE HUH. ALL
RIGHT WELL GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM PLEASED TO BE
HERE TO PRESENT AB THREE FORTY
FIVE MY ACCESSORY DWELLING UNIT
BILL OR A DO YOU BILL ALL OUR
GRANNY FLAT BILL FOR THOSE WHO
USED TO CALL OF THAT. AB THREE
FORTY FIVE WOULD MAKE A MODEST
CHANGES TO A CURRENT LAW BY
REMOVING EXISTING BARRIERS FOR
NONPROFIT OF NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE OWNERSHIP.
DEVELOPERS BUILDING HOMES FOR
VERY LOW AND EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. NOW LET ME
BE CLEAR. FIRST IT IS A CHOICE
FOR A PROPERTY OWNER TO BUILD A
DAY DO YOU. SECOND IT'S ANOTHER
CHOICE TO CONVEY OR TRANSFER
THAT EIGHTY YOU TO A NON PROFIT.
THIS MEASURE WOULD ALLOW THE
SEPARATE SALE OF AN EIGHTY YOU
IN LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES AS THE
DEFAULT IN CALIFORNIA RATHER
THAN REQUIRING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THE FIRST PASSED
ORDINANCES WHICH CAN BE AS WE
ALL KNOW VERY LENGTHY AND DRAWN
OUT PROCESSES. BY REMOVING THIS
REQUIREMENT AND ADDING LANGUAGE
CLARIFYING THE TENANT IN COMMON
AGREEMENT THIS MEASURE WILL
ALLOW NONPROFITS LIKE HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY TO EXPAND THE
REACH OFFERING ADDITIONAL
OWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES. AND I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE HABITAT
HUMANITY AS I'VE WORKED
DIRECTLY WITH THEM AND FOR MANY
OF YOU WHO HAVEN'T WORKED WITH
THEM THEY REALLY LITERALLY GIVE
THE KEYS TO HOMEOWNERS UP WITH
A PARTNERSHIP PROJECTS. AS WE
KNOW ALL TOO WELL BEFORE THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC OUR
STATE WAS FACING ONE OF THE
WORST HOUSING CRISIS IS. AND
CONTINUES TO NOTHING HAS
CHANGED SINCE THE PANDEMIC ONLY
THAT THE OUTCOMES ARE EVEN
WORSE WE KNOW THAT MANY
FAMILIES ARE AT THE RISK OF
LOSING HOMES BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC BUT EVEN THOSE
FAMILIES BEFORE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO OWN A HOME IS VERY ELUSIVE
FOR SO MANY CALIFORNIANS. WITH
THAT ONE OF THE REASONS IS
SIMPLY HOUSING PRODUCTION. WE
KNOW THAT THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
ATTEMPTS TO BRING HOUSING
PRODUCTION BILLS TO OUR STATE
AND MANY HAVE BEEN BLOCKED OR
STOPPED. AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THAT'S ONE OF THE PRIMARY
REASONS FOR THE INCREASE COST.
MY DAUGHTER HERSELF JUST
PURCHASED A HOUSE. IN FULLER
TEN FOR ALL OVER THE MEDIUM
PRICE BECAUSE OF BIDDING WARS A
NINETEEN TWENTIES VERY SMALL
WITH ALMOST NO YARD HOME. AT A
VERY HIGH PRICE BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT VERY MANY HOMES AVAILABLE.
WITH THAT. I BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL WILL ADD TO OUR STOCK OF
HOUSING IT WILL ADD FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS PROPERTY OWNERS
THAT CHOOSE AN OPTION FOR
SOMEBODY TO LIVE ON THEIR
PROPERTY AND FOR THEM TO CONVEY
THAT TO NONPROFIT AFTER CHOICE
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE. TWO
WITNESSES. AND THE HERE TO
SHARE INFORMATION IS DEBBIE.
RKL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY. MODERATOR
WE WILL TAKE THE BOTH THE
WITNESSES DEBBIE AND SUSAN MAN
THAT. YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DEBBIE OUR
ACCOUNT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AND I'M REPRESENTING THE VIEWS
OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
AFFILIATES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB THREE FORTY FIVE AND
STAND ALONGSIDE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SHARON QUIRK SILVA INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE OWNER
OCCUPIED UNITS. AND MANY OF YOU
KNOW HABITAT IS AN AFFORDABLE
HOME DEVELOPER AND LENDER FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
HOUSEHOLDS WE SERVE OUR LOW
INCOME WORKING FAMILIES AND
OVER TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP THROUGH HABITAT.
pHOMEOWNERS ARE HOUSEHOLDS OF
COLOR AND OVER 15% INCLUDE AT
THAT CAN FAMILY MEMBER I REALLY
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION DOES NOT CHANGE THE
EXISTING HOME DEVELOPMENT
APPROVAL PROCESS. HABITAT AND
ANY OTHER NONPROFIT BUILDERS
WOULD STILL NEED TO FOLLOW THE
SAME THE MIDDLE PROCESS WITH AN
APPLICATION THE REVIEW AND THE
APPROVAL REQUIRED BY LOCAL
PLANNING AND BUILDING
DEPARTMENT WHAT THE LEGISLATION
REALLY DOES IS IT SERVES TO
REMOVE THE EXTRA BURDEN OF
REQUIRING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ADOPT A SEPARATE ORDINANCE
WHICH IS A DETERRENT FOR
DEVELOPERS WE HAVE HABITAT
AFFILIATE TO INQUIRED ABOUT.
BUILDING MORE ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS FOR LOW INCOME
OWNERSHIP AND BEING ABLE TO
EXPAND OF LAND USE WHICH IS ONE
OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE ASPECTS
OF ANY DEVELOPMENT BUT THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EXTRA TIME
AND EFFORT THAT IT WOULD TAKE
TO WORK WITH CITIES TO ADOPT
BEFORE EVEN STARTING. A PROJECT
APPROVAL PROCESS. INCREASE
AFFORDABLE PRODUCTION ESSENTIAL
FOR CAL. REMOVING BARRIERS LOST
MAINTAINING LOCAL APPROVAL
PROCESS EASIER WOULD SAVE
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE DEVELOPERS
LIKE HABITAT VALUABLE TIME AND
MONEY. AND THAT LEGISLATION
WOULD ALLOW EIGHTY YOU
DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE APPROVED
TO BE SOLD FIVE RIGHT RATHER
THAN REQUIRING THE
EXTRAVAGANCE. BY REMOVING OF
THE ORDINANCE MORE AFFORDABLE
UNITS WILL BE BUILT AND SOLD TO
LOW INCOME BUYERS AND OFTEN
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS OF COLOR
THIS WOULD ALLOW. US ALL TO
HELP CLOSE THE RACIAL GAP IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP. ADDITIONALLY AS
MENTIONED THE BILL PROVIDES
CLARITY IN THE LAW BY
DESCRIBING THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE TENANT IN COMMON AGREEMENT
NEEDING AND NEEDED UNDER THIS
PROVISION. IT WOULD EASE THE
BARRIERS TO DEVELOPMENT AND
INCREASE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
YOU- YOU. MAKE BETTER USE LAND
AND- THE NUMBER LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNER. JUST AS A QUICK
SUCCESS STORY TO ILLUSTRATE WE
WERE ABLE TO APPLY THAT EIGHTY
LEGISLATION IN. BUTTE COUNTY
AND THEY WERE ABLE TO ACQUIRE
THREE PARCELS THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO SERVE THREE HOMEOWNERS
AND NAME. AND TO THE
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED
THEY WERE ABLE TO TURN THAT
INTO SERVING SIX NEW HOMEOWNERS
CAN FIVE OF THEM HAD BEEN
DISPLACED BY THE CAMP WILD
FIRES. IF THIS DEAL LEGISLATION
AB THREE FORTY FIVE WITH IN
PLACE THEY WOULD HAVE SAVED
SIGNIFICANT TIME AND MONEY AND
BEEN ABLE TO SERVICE HOMEOWNERS
QUICKER. AB EIGHT THREE FORTY
FIVE WILL HELP INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE HOME TO
HELP CLOSE THE OWNERSHIP GAP
ACROSS RACE AND ETHNICITY AND
HELP REDUCE THE COST. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA IS GRATEFUL
FOR THE TREMENDOUS
CONSIDERATION OF THIS IMPORTANT
DEL AND WE ARE CAN HIDE. THE
KEY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANOTHER WAY IN. SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY MEMBERS
DOESN'T MATTER NOT- LIKE HEALTH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS REPRESENTING-
BIRD AFFINITY COMPLAINING AND
URBAN RESEARCH INSTITUTION AS
WELL CALIFORNIA YIMBY- WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
BECAUSE THE BEST- THIS
LEGISLATION REALLY- BRING-
BRING THE MINUTE CURRENT EIGHTY
LAW WHICH MANDATES EIGHTY YOU'D
BE ALLOWED STATEWIDE- BUT IT IT
AND IT STILL ALLOWED LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SHOULD THEY
CHOOSE TO PASS CODE NINJAS. ON
EIGHTY LEGISLATION- TO PROCEED
WITH THAT PROCESS- WE FIND THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND ARE
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN'S A LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THAT
INCREASED ALL MONISHA FOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- PRIMARILY
AND HISTORICALLY EXCLUSIVE
COMMUNITIES THAT AFRICAN
GENERATIONAL WEALTH BUILDING
OPPORTUNITIES AND ECONOMIC
STABILITY TO THOSE THAT HAVE
FREQUENTLY BEEN
DISENFRANCHISED- FROM
OWNERSHIP. SO WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR HER- LEADERSHIP TODAY I'M
OFTEN HERE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SHOULD THERE BE
QUESTION THANK YOU GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
WITNESS PRIMARY. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. HERE'S NOT- AND
THERE'S ANY OF IT OPPOSITION
ROOM FORTY TWO OR TWO. SEEING
NONE- MODERATOR IF YOU'D LIKE
TO OPEN UP THE LINES AGAIN AND
THAT WOULD BE FOR OPPOSITION
AND FOR- SUPPORT- JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION. I'M SORRY I
MISSED. JUST NAME OF IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. HERE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE FOUR FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN. ZERO ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION.
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE'LL GET
LINE NUMBER. OUR FIRST FINAL
COME FROM ONE TO THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LAUREN TABLE AND SEAT
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT. AND
WE HAVE ONE MORE LINE IN HERE.
ONE MOMENT WHERE WE GATHER
THEIR NUMBER. CANNELLA COME
FROM NINE TO FORTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- HI ADAM CHEN TOOK
ON BEHALF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE FOUR FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATE OR
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. UGH QUESTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAR HARBOR.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FOR THIS
LEGISLATION I WAS WONDERING-
SINCE THE LAURA FRIEDMAN BILL
CREATED THIS WHEN TO AFFECTED
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY AND
THEN WE'VE BEEN IN A PANDEMIC-
I'M NOT SURE. THERE'S EVIDENCE
OUT THERE THAT SHOWS THAT
CITIES ARE PURPOSELY
OBSTRUCTING THE ORDINANCE I'VE
BEEN I WAS ON THE AND SENATE
CITY COUNCIL EIGHTY YEARS ARE
HIGHLY- ACCEPTABLE FORM OF
HOUSING IN MY CITY BUT I
BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY IN THE
NEED FOR LOCAL CONTROL AND
PASSING AN ORDINANCE. THAT
ALLOWS THIS TYPE OF DEVELOPMENT
IS NOT ONEROUS OR DIFFICULT AND
SO I THINK IT'S PREMATURE TO
SAY THAT WE HAVE TO DO BY RIGHT
AND WE HAVE TO FORCE ALL CITIES
TO DO THIS. BECAUSE IT DOES GET
RID OF SINGLE FAMILY ZONING AND
IT DOES GIVE A TURN CONVEYANCER
NONPROFIT AND THEY'RE GOOD
NONPROFITS LIKE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY WHICH I HAVE BUILT
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY HOUSES
WHEN I WAS A BERKELEY. IT'S A
GREAT ORGANIZATION BUT IF IT'S
ANY NONPROFIT SO THERE ARE SOME
BAD ACTORS OUT THERE SO I THINK
IT'S PREMATURE TO SAY WE NEED
TO GO STRAIGHT TO THE BY RIGHT
THAT IT'S NOT WORKING I THINK
THAT THERE'S EVIDENCE AFTER THE
PANDEMIC THAT IS NOT WORKING. I
THINK THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
TO BRING BACK THEN BUT TO SAY
WE'RE GONNA DO IT BY RIGHT AND
WE TAKE FOR AWAY SINGLE FAMILY
ZONING AND PLACES WHERE EIGHTY
WAS ARE CURRENTLY ACCEPTABLE
MAKING IT PERHAPS NOT
ACCEPTABLE IN OTHER PLACES- IS
NOT THE WAY TO INCREASE.
HOUSING STUFF AND I'LL BE
OPPOSING THE BILL. THANK YOU DE
ASK ME QUESTION AND THE
QUESTION WAS HAVE WE SEEN ANY
EVIDENCE- RELATED TO. ONEROUS
OBJECTIONS TO EIGHTY USE I
WOULD FIRSTHAND SAY I'VE NOT
SEEN ONEROUS OBJECTIONS BUT
WHAT I WOULD SAY AT THE FOR
EVEN THE CURRENT PROJECT.
PROCESSES WITH THE LEGISLATION
THAT WE HAVE PASSED IN LAST
HANDFUL OF YEARS. THE LAST TWO
YEARS SPECIFICALLY. THEY STILL
ARE VERY UNCLEAR ON SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE WHICH WE ACTUALLY HAD
ADDITIONAL PIECES OF
LEGISLATION. BUT DECIDED NOT TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THOSE- BY
MYSELF HAVE LOOKED INTO NAY D.
YOU ON OUR OWN PROPERTY. AND AS
MUCH WORK AS WE'VE DONE IN THE
STATE THERE STILL ARE CITIES
AND IT IS CITY BY CITY I KNOW
IN YOUR AREA. THEY ARE MUCH
SWIFTER AS YOU ALL EVEN HAVE A
SHELF READY PLANS WHICH- WE
WOULD LIKE TO GET TO THAT. BUT
IT DEPENDS ON THE CITY. BUT AS
FAR AS THE BY RIGHT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AUTHORIZING. BUT
IT STILL REMAINS WITH THE
SELLER IN NO WAY ARE WE
SUGGESTING THAT THE CITY COME
IN. TO EACH DEVELOPMENT OR
SINGLE FAMILY HOME AND SAY YOU
HAVE TO BUILD A NAY D. YOU. OR
YOU MAY NOT ONLY HAVE TO BUILD
A DO YOU. BUT IN ADDITION YOU
HAVE TO CONVEY THAT TO. A NON
PROFIT SO THIS IS AN EXTRA TOOL
IN THE TOOL KIT. AND THE MAIN
REASON THAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON
DOING THIS IS TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THOSE THAT CHOOSE TO BE
ABLE TO. REDUCE THE LENGTH OF
TIME THAT IT'S TAKING TO BE
READY TO I MEAN WE CAN'T HAVE
EACH CITY AS WAS NOTED- LOOK AT
THE END OF. AND VOTE ON AN
ORDINANCE OR NOT. AND WE KNOW
THAT THOSE CAN TAKE YEARS AND
SOMETIMES A NEVER HAD.
SERIOUSLY IF THEY CANNOT BUT-
EACH CITY IS DIFFERENT BUT THAT
THAT'S OUR FOCUS ON THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I- WANT TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT- AND I APPRECIATE
THE INTERCHANGE BETWEEN TWO IN
MY COLLEAGUES I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THE- THAT. THAT WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY DOING BECAUSE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A BILL THAT
AFFECTS SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCE
ZONING. BOB WHAT IT DOES ALL
THAT THAT THAT WE HAVE A THIS
IS A VERY CONTROVERSIAL TOPIC
BECAUSE WE HAVE OTHER.
LEGISLATION PENDING IN THE
LEGISLATURE THAT ALLOWS FOR.
LOT SPLITS AND DUPLEXES TO BE
BUILT AND A DUPLEX IS NOT A
SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCE WHAT
THIS DOES IS IT ALLOWS. A LOT
SPLIT. AND FOR THERE TO BE TO
SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCES. WHICH
TO MY MIND IS VERY DIFFERENT-
AND IS VERY COMPATIBLE WITH
THE- EXISTING NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT THE LOTS WOULD BE SMALLER
AND IT INCREASES THE DENSITY OF
A- VERY. MARGINAL WAY I DON'T
SEE THIS. TAKING OVER ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOODS OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT IS NOT INTENDED TO DO THAT
IT'S INTENDED TO PROVIDE-
NONPROFITS THAT- SERVE LOW
INCOME CONSTITUENCIES. AND AN
OPTION FOR CREATING SOME
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABILITY AND
CURRENTLY ON AFFORDABLE
NEIGHBORHOODS WHICH IS MOST
NEIGHBORHOODS- UNFORTUNATELY-
BUT I DO WANT TO UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BIT BETTER- AND
STRUCTURALLY HOW THIS WORKS IS
THE- IS THE INTENT. HERE THAT.
NONPROFITS WILL PURCHASE AN
ENTIRE PROPERTY AND- AND THEN
DO A LOT SPLIT- OR IS THE
INTENT FOR THE NONPROFIT TO
WORK WITH AN EXISTING HOMEOWNER
TO DO A LOT SPLIT AND THEN. THE
LATTER THE LETTER AS FAR AS
WORKING WITH EXISTING HOMEOWNER
SITE GO AHEAD SO MY QUESTION IS
IN THAT SITUATION- HOW IS THE
VALUE OF THE- EIGHTY YOU PART
OF A OF THE LOT- HOW IS THAT
VALUE DETERMINED BECAUSE IF
IT'S BEING- IF IT'S BECOMING. A
GOT LOW INCOME HOUSING. IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THE OWNER OF-
WHO'S SELLING OFF THE- THAT THE
SPLIT PART OF A LOT IS NOT
GOING TO RECEIVE FAIR MARKET I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DETERMINE
FOR MARKET VALUE I GUESS. I
THINK THAT. HOME OWNERS DON'T
GET SHORT CHANGED IN THE
PROCESS. RIGHT AND I THINK IT
IS THE CHOICE OF THE OWNER AND
THE SENSE THAT THEY WOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY IN ESSENCE
ARE- WORKING WITH HABITAT WHICH
FOCUSES ON- INDIVIDUALS. WHO
ARE. IN THE- LOW TO VERY LOW.
INCOME BRACKET ã BRACKET AND
SO THIS WOULD BE AN COULD SEEN
BE SEEN AS A WAY TO HELP SAYS A
SUBSIDIZED. THIS PROPERTY SO
THAT SOMEBODY COULD GET INTO A
PIECE OF PROPERTY. THAT
WOULDN'T TYPICALLY BE ABLE TO-
THE HABITAT PROPERTIES. THAT
ARE NOT INVOLVED WITH THEY DO
USE AS YOU KNOW IN MANY CITIES.
IT'S USUALLY THE CITY AS A
PARTNER- THAT IS WORKING
TOGETHER WITH HABITAT AND MANY
pACTUALLY GIVEN AND THAT ALLOWS
THIS PARTNERSHIP TO TAKE PLACE-
BUT AS FAR AS THE TECHNICAL
DETAILS I DON'T HAVE THOSE WITH
ME. AND FRENEMY BUT THE ENTIRE
IDEA IS THAT YOU HAVE A LOT.
YOU'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH
HABITAT. TO GET IN. EXTREMELY
LOW TO LOW INCOME PERSON TO
TAKE THAT PROPERTY. AND TO
CONVEY IT THROUGH THE NONPROFIT
SO I'M SUFFICIENTLY SATISFIED
TO OF THAT THE BILL'S GOING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION OF VOTE FOR
TODAY AND YOUR SPONSORS ARE
LISTENING AND KNOW HOW TO REACH
ME AND I. JUST ASKED THEM TO-
SET UP A MEETING WITH ME SO I
CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND AND-
PERHAPS EVEN HELP ACROSS SOME
OF THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL.
THANK YOUNG ONE WHO'S BEEN
INTENSELY. INTERESTED IN EIGHTY
YEARS FROM. WELL KNOW YOU YOU
HAVE BEEN THE IN EIGHTY USE
THAT- WELL THAT'S HOW I GOT
INVOLVED. AFTER I. EXACTLY ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MANY
MEMBERS OKAY ALL RIGHT THE VICE
WHEN HE ENTERTAINMENT OKAY WE
HAVE MOTION BY A PHONE NUMBER
RAMOS OF A SECOND BY ROB
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS.
LET'S SEE HERE- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I JUST WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. BY ALLOWING
QUALIFIED NONPROFITS TO CONVEY
TO YOU SEPARATELY FROM THE
PRIMARY RESIDENCE YOUR BILL
WILL HELP INCREASE HOME.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES YOU HAVE FOUND A WAY
TO INCREASE HOMEOWNERSHIP
WITHOUT ALTERING OR INFRINGING
ON THE LOCAL DEVELOPMENT
APPROVAL PROCESS OR REQUIRING
NEW SOURCES OF STATE FUNDING
THAT IS QUITE A FEAT. I'M
PLEASED TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY- MOTION IS TO PASS AND
RIVER FOR TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY HI
WE- HIGH LACKEY I'M LUCKY I
BLOOM I FLEW I'VE LEARNED OVER
NOW OR MORE RIGHT NOW. A LOS.
HELLO THREE OF US THE THREE
SIDE REED HI ROBERT READ VOEPEL
HOTEL HI. SEVEN ONE. THANK YOU
OKAY BILLS OUT THANK YOU VERY
SOME- SO DONE IT LOOKS LIKE FOR
OF ALL I FOR TO ME SOME THAT WE
A NEW MEMBER ON OUR TEAM RESELL
LANCASTER PLANCHET PLANTS GET
LANCASTER IS OUR NEW-
SECRETARY. AND OF COURSE
SERVICE HAMMERTON FINANCING
WORDS BISHOP MURRY SAID NUMBER
IS A WORRISOME- AND- WE'RE TO
KEEP GOING DOWNSIDE WANTED
SEVEN FOR WE GO ON SOME REAL
NOW LIFT THE CALL ALLOW MEMBERS
TO ADD ON TO THE FOLLOWING
BILLS. AB SEVEN TWENTY SIX
SECRETARY. THREE OF US
THREE OF US I THE BOOK IS
CURRENTLY EIGHT ZERO- SEVEN SIX
IS OUT EIGHT ZERO CONSENT
CALENDAR. THREE OF US
THREE OF US SITE ARLACCHI WACKY.
FIVE ZERO EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO
THANK YOU CONSENT CALENDARS OUT
COMMITTEE RULES. THREE OF US
HELLO ROBERT RIVAS. WELL I
THINK I NEED COMMITTEE RULES OF
THE THINGS JUST LOSE BEGINNING
YEAH. RIGHT UP TO. ROBERT RIVAS
RIGHT SO THAT'S EIGHT ZERO OF
THE COMMITTEE WILL ALSO LOSE
ISN'T RIVAS IS ARE GOOD TO GO.
THE NEEDS YOU GET THE- NO WE
DIDN'T DO THE COMMITTEE RULES
IN THE BEGINNING. YOU DID VOTE
ARE YOU WERE. RIGHT. SO THAT IS.
THOSE ARE EIGHT ZERO THAT'S
GREAT AND THANK YOU FOR MUCH
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
THE PREP FOR EVERYONE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS APPRECIATE
WE'LL SEE YOU. A COUPLE OF
WEEKS. MEETING ADJOURNED I JUST
YEAH I KNOW.